and the Oscar goes to Mark ryance Bridge
of spies I've always just adored
stories hearing them seeing them being
in them so for me to have the chance to
work with I think one of the greatest
storytellers of our time Steven
Spielberg has just been such an honor he
leads with such love that he's
surrounded by Masters in every Craft on
his film every craft not the least Mr
Tom Hanks as a face of the film I meet
many people in the streets and it's
lovely to have them they're always
saying to me would it help and all that
stuff and I think uh if you ever wonder
about acting with Tom Hanks would it
help the answer is clearly
yes I want to just say thank you to my
fellow nominees I don't know how they
separate my acting from your glorious
acting and these wonderful films that
you're in which everyone must see I
don't know how they separated the five
of us from all the other supporting
actors who are making films at the
moment it's a wonderful time to be an
actor and I'm proud to be part of it
thank you